here's the best way to not get bad
advice the first one is what is this
person's intention if the person has any
intention that would benefit them from
the advice they're giving me I
automatically toss it out or I take it
with a massive grain of salt the second
thing do they have enough context in my
situation and 99.9 of the time they
don't because the best person whose
context to your situation is you the
third one is macro timing did this
advice work in the 80s and not work
today is it a fundamental principle or
is it an environmental factor and then
the final piece how does it apply to me
specifically within this timing of my
career and it doesn't even matter nearly
as much about how old you are but more
so what season of Entrepreneurship
you're in it's when I think through all
four of those lenses when I look at
something that crosses all four that's
the advice I listen to